Russian backed officials in the occupied
city of donet say the blast happened in
a civilian area of Market stores and
shops which was crowded with
Shoppers the Russian government has
condemned what it calls a brutal
terrorist
attack images taken just after the
explosion appearing to show extensive
damage with dead and injured victims
lying in the
streets a bang and then I looked up
there was smoke with a burst water pipe
and steam and then I approached and
there were no legs anymore torn off
already other relatives living nearby
have been learning of the fate of their
loved
ones some woman called from my wife's
phone I was at work she said that's it
your wife is gone that's
all the blast also caused extensive
damage to surrounding buildings in a
part of Russian occupies dunesque that
has witnessed years of
fighting and when will there be peace it
has been like this for 10 years already
at this rate we will all eventually be
killed this part of DK is less than 15
km from the fighting on the front line
with both Ukraine and Russia accusing
each other of escalating attacks on
civilian
areas Benton Monahan Al jazer
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer